what kind of stuff could you survive do
you think Nick a flood flood I'll name
something you tell me okay flood
probably not not a strong swimmer okay
so just a second ago you could in hey
can I started to think about okay so
flood is done but fire fire I think I
could survive okay say it's an indoor
and outdoor fire I'm not talking about
like a space heater you know that kills
poor people outside of Chicago every
year I'm talking about a real heater you
know I'm talking about the [ __ ] merry
on the weeds you're out there chasing
boughs are kind of [ __ ]
yeah you don't have to swim in fire I
still think I think I could do it you
could iron well what were you there's
fire outside there's fire in the wood
you're running what do you do it seems
it always seems like if you just go fast
enough through fire you don't like catch
on fire so I think I just run straight
through it okay who's that guy running
through the fire over there that's Nick
my theory could be wrong no I like it
the have row look I'll be behind you
okay okay let's think of another one um
hail hail great with hail okay um Oh
buzzards big you know large animal air
attack Birds kind of freaked me out too
I'm even get scared going over that
whole foods someone yeah purchasing that
birds get super aggressive and they're
not afraid of you oh I saw two ah I
don't when I was a falcon or just a
pigeon the head [ __ ] something wrong
with it but I saw one of them attack
this Filipino lady and it was intense
dude stole a whole like kind of a small
bag of groceries but took the whole
[ __ ] thing bro I think he must have
known she was his natural enemy don't
don't they eat a lot of bird oh I don't
know if she said she was on her
menstrual cycle she thought that that's
what it was and she kept asking me I'm
like I don't [ __ ] know I don't know
if pigeons attack people because they're
you know menstruating okay let's get
into some other calls a man this is
interesting evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw I mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes your life well you could watch
this one or
watch this one watch this one watch
one watches one